now for our main event again the
resolution reads upward mobility of
black Americans lies in rejecting the
policies of progressive government while
making the most of the opportunities
offered by American society vote yes no
yes no or undecided on the resolution
here to defend the resolution is Jacob
Riley Manhattan Institute senior fellow
Jacob Riley Jacob please come to the
stage
yeah
arguing against the resolution will be
NYU Professor nikhil Singh nikhil please
come to the stage
okay
and uh all right and uh here to speak
for the affirmative Jason you've got 18
minutes to speak for the affirmative
take the podium take it away Jason
has
anyone here seen the movie hidden
figures
it was a
released in 2016.
for those who haven't
um
hidden figures is a true story
tell us the true story of
three remarkable black mathematicians
who helped NASA launch its space
exploration program in the 1950s and 60s
um their names are Dorothy Vaughn Mary
Jackson
and Katherine Johnson Vaughn taught
computer programming to other black
women after World War II and eventually
became the agency's first black
supervisor
Johnson initially worked under Vaughn
and then went on to become NASA's first
black female
engineer
and Johnson calculated the rocket
trajectories
for NASA's first human space flights in
the early 1960s
and also helped land Neil Armstrong on
the moon in 1969
now the film's primary focus is the
everyday lives of these women while
working at NASA and how they coped with
the ugly racist and sexist attitudes of
the Jim Crow era
it was a big hit with moviegoers many of
whom were unaware that black mines had
helped America win the Space Race
Against the Soviet Union
but hidden figures is more than a story
about unsung black math whizzes
it doubles as a story about black upward
Mobility
in the post world
in the post-war period progress that was
taking place notwithstanding all manner
of laws and policies and Customs that
openly discriminated against blacks
the movie is based on a book of the same
Title by Margot shetterly the daughter
of a retired black NASA scientist and
Chevrolet's book goes much deeper than
the film does into describing working
class and middle class black communities
that produce these remarkable women
Vaughn was born in 1910. learned to read
from her parents before starting school
graduated from high school as class
valedictorian at age 15.
she won a scholarship to Wilbur Force
University in Ohio the oldest
black private college in the United
States where she majored in math and
graduated in 1929.
at Wilberforce a professor recommended
her for graduate study in mathematics at
Howard University
where the department was run by two
black mathematicians who had earned
their doctorates from Cornell in the
University of Pennsylvania
Mary Jackson was a second generation
college graduate born in Hampton
Virginia and earned degrees in math and
physical science in 1943 from another
black college Hampton University which
was then known as Hampton Institute
shetterly writes the Jackson quote
followed the family tradition of
enrolling in Hampton Institute which had
graduated her father her mother and
several of her older siblings
she explains how quote the school's
philosophy of negro advancement through
self-help and practical and Industrial
training the Hampton idea
closely associated with Booker T
Washington the college's most famous
graduate
mirrored the aspirations and philosophy
of the surrounding black community
Catherine Johnson the book's third
heroine was born in 1918 which is 14
years old when she completed high school
and enrolled at West Virginia Institute
another black college
shatterly writes that by her junior year
Catherine had tackled every Math course
in the school's catalog and had been
taken under the wing of a gifted young
math professor named William clayder
who created advanced math classes just
for her
shetterly wrote that Clayton had earned
his own doctorate in math from the
University of Pennsylvania in 1933.
Catherine's other black Mentor at that
college was a chemist and mathematician
named Angie Turner King who received
Advanced degrees from Cornell in 1931
University of Pittsburgh in 1955.
now these thumbnail sketches of Black
America in the early and middle Decades
of the 20th century may surprise people
today who have come to associate black
communities with crime and violence and
underperforming schools and single
parenting and high levels of
unemployment
the book is a reminder that things used
to be much much different
when Dorothy Vaughn first arrived and
segregated Newport News Virginia in 1943
to start our job at NASA
she lived with an elderly black couple
in the city's East End Neighborhood
they owned a grocery store and took in
borders
shatterly writes that the East End was
quote a larger version of what Dorothy
had left behind in rural West Virginia
it was quote populated by stable negro
families in well-maintained homes
thriving local businesses and a growing
middle class
on the corner of the block where she
lived a pharmacist had purchased a lot
was opening the city's first negro
Pharmacy
a new hospital had just opened earlier
in the year organized by black doctors
and constructed by black architects
again this is 1943.
this story of what was happening in
America among black people who were only
a couple Generations removed from
slavery and still living under legally
enforced submission has received nowhere
near the amount of tension that it
deserves
it defies our expectations it challenges
a lot of what we think about American
history
wrote
she's right
and the implications of this history go
far beyond the immediate subject matter
which is why I wanted to participate in
this event this evening
these stories of black accomplishment in
this previous era raised important
questions about social and economic
inequality today what's driving it and
how best to address it
now these women were by no means typical
of black people of that era most of whom
were poor and unskilled
in 1940 87 percent of black families
lived below the poverty line
and only about five percent of black
adults were engaged in non-manual
white-collar work
so these women were very much the
exceptions to that Norm
but they also represented a new black
Vanguard
by 1960
the poverty rate for blacks had fallen
nearly in half from 87 percent to 47
percent
it's often stated and widely assumed
that today's black middle class
owes its existence and its continuation
to affirmative action in other
government programs
but this gets the order wrong
the 40 percentage Point drop in Black
poverty occurred well before the war on
poverty and other Great Society
initiatives were launched in the late
1960s and expanded in the 1970s
it occurred before the Civil Rights Act
of 1964 and the Voting Rights Act of
1965 had passed it occurred long before
not only the election of a black
president but before blacks had any
significant political clout in Congress
or had won mayoral elections and major
American cities with large black
populations
and it predated the affirmative action
hiring and preferential College
admission policies that were implemented
in Earnest beginning in the 1970s
this was Peak Jim Crow
when housing and employment were sharply
limited for blacks
and they were shut out of union jobs in
many other professions dominated by
whites
yet none of those barriers proved to be
insurmountable
in the three decades between 1940 and
1970 the proportion of black people
holding White Collar jobs Rose
dramatically from 5 to 22 percent of the
men and from 6 percent to 36 percent of
the women
according to the social scientist
Stephen and Abigail tharnstrom
by 1970 over a fifth of black men and
over a third of black women were in
middle class occupations
four times as many in the case of men
and six times as many in the case of
women compared with three decades
earlier
before World War II Black bookkeepers
and secretaries and stenographers and
mail carriers were rare by 1970 they
were common
in fact the thornstom's right the growth
of the black middle class long predates
the adoption of race-conscious social
policies
in some ways the map the black middle
class was expanding more rapidly before
1970 than after unquote
now the thunderstorms are political
conservatives
but I want to point out that social
scientists on the political left who
have looked at the same data have
reached the same conclusion
for example here's Harvard's Robert
Putnam in his 2020 book The upswing
the persistent exclusion of people of
color from the white American mainstream
after the abolition of slavery is an
indelible blot on this nation's history
he writes however the story is more
complex than it appears
as we look closely at a variety of
measures spanning the 20th century two
surprises emerge he writes first
progress toward equality for blacks
didn't begin in 1965.
by many measures blacks were moving
toward parity with whites well before
the victories of the Civil Rights
Revolution despite the limitations
imposed by Jim Crow
and second
after the Civil Rights Movement and he
italicizes after
that long-standing Trend toward Racial
equality
slowed
stopped
and even reversed course unquote
he uses several examples to illustrate
this I'll cite two of them
here he is on education trends
quote despite the fact that white
educational attainment was also Rising
between 1940 and 1970. black education
entertainment was Rising even faster
so the black white Gap was narrowing
as blacks began to catch up with whites
but after 1970 that ketchup progress
drastically slowed and in the case of
high school actually ended
I'm sorry drastically slowed in the case
of high school and ended in the case of
college
here's Putnam on income disparities
overall he writes black incomes Rose
relative to White incomes for the first
two thirds of the century
and most Scholars agree that income
levels by race converged at the greatest
rate between 1940 and 1970.
again we're not just talking about black
absolute gains
we're talking about black gains relative
to White gains
whites were gaining two they were not
standing still blacks were catching them
social inequality was narrowing during
this period at a pace that has never
been replicated that has never come
close to being replicated
which brings me to the resolution upward
Mobility for black Americans lies in
rejecting the policies of progressive
government while making the most of
opportunities offered by American
society
the reason I believe that statement is
true has nothing to do with politics or
ideology it's simply what history has
demonstrated and demonstrated
empirically
it's simply an accurate reading of the
data
the greatest strides by blacks have not
been made via government social welfare
programs or racial preferences
they have not been made in the era of
affirmative action which again began in
Earnest in the 1970s they were made in
the era prior to affirmative action and
welfare state expansions
they've been made by blacks taking
advantage of opportunities that have
been afforded them
in 1940 there was a severe labor
shortage due to World War II
and blacks were given access to labor
markets that had previously been close
to them
blacks were not given special access or
preferential access
they were simply given access in many
cases limited access
and took advantage of that
history shows that blacks have fared far
better under equal treatment laws and
policies than they have under racial
preferences however well intended
in closing let me stress two things
first none of this is an is an attempt
to romanticize Jim Crow
that is not the goal of Margot shetterly
not the goal of the thurnstroms not the
goal of Robert Putnam and certainly not
my goal
that was a horrific period for blacks
and an embarrassment for a country with
our professed ideals
the point is not to suggest that blacks
were advancing because of segregation
the point is that they were advancing
notwithstanding it
secondly
no one is arguing that racism in America
is somehow behind us
that it doesn't exist
I don't believe that's true in fact I
don't believe it will ever be true
nor do I believe that race has unpassed
or present has played no role in
hampering upward Mobility it has
and it does and I think I need to stress
that because
the response to that is often people
pointing out the study or that study
showing some racial disparity employer
hiring or bank loans or something to
show that racism still exists you'll get
no objection from me on that front
the challenge is figuring out how much
of a role it plays in 21st century
racial disparities and how much of a
role other non-racial factors may be
playing
blacks the previous era had to deal with
a much more adversarial society yet by
many measures they had much better
outcomes in poverty home ownership
income crime rates educational
attainments and many more areas
Progressive policies do not deserve the
credit they are given they make blacks
who largely lifted themselves out of
poverty looked like people who owe their
advancement to government programs and
racial preferences
to anyone who knows black history that's
not only incorrect it's insulting I'll
stop there
the pill
good evening everyone
um I I want to say thanks to Gene and to
to Nick Gillespie to reason so forth so
forum for having me back again and I I
want to thank Jason too I really
appreciated his remarks and mine will be
in a slightly different register it's
not so much a story uh of individuals as
a as much as it is a story of a period
but I think Jason's actually set the
framework for us very well by Framing
this as being about the period from the
1940s to the 1970s and then from the
period of from the 1970s to the present
and how we think about history is really
going to play a big a big role in what I
have to say tonight
um and I think you'll you'll see this is
going to be an interesting discussion so
I want to begin by defining my own
understanding of the resolution that I'm
arguing against
and of course a resolution like this is
framed in very broad terms so I want to
make my own terms clear and you can
decide if if you agree with me or
whether I'm being tendentious here
first I want to be clear that I don't
think it makes sense for anyone least of
all African Americans not to make the
most of the opportunities afforded by
American society
it is if that is all there is to this
discussion then I might as well concede
now
but for my money the real questions
before us are one what are the
opportunities afforded by American
society
especially to people of modest means and
education
and how are they promoted or inhibited
by the policies of progressive
government
when I think of opportunities what comes
to mind are basic requisites for a good
standard of living
adequate income decent shelter access to
time for worship Leisure and education
and if we disagree on any of that we can
discuss it later
some people might for example might
think that the real opportunity offered
by American society is the chance to get
rich
but I think most of us are motivated by
a more modest ambition to achieve what
we need to thrive to care for ourselves
and those who are dear to us
here's where it gets contentious
what do we mean by the policies of
progressive government
and how do they promote or inhibit
opportunities for human flourishing in
the terms that I have just outlined
for example by progressive government do
we mean regulations on business that
ensure safe food and clean drinking
water
do we mean taxing wealthier people at a
higher rate
do we mean access to government insured
home mortgages government supported
health care and Social Security
do we mean access to free public
education and affordable public higher
education
do we mean government support of the
right of workers to organize into trade
unions and bargain over wages and
working conditions
do we mean the existence of legal
Frameworks that monitor and sanction
racial discrimination particularly in
housing and employment
in the most minimal but also
historically accurate sense every single
thing I just listed is a major policy
achievement of progressive government in
the United States since the 1940s
each of these policy achievements
moreover at one time or another
engendered Fierce opposition from
conservative and reactionary opponents
even if some of them such as Social
Security
or progressive taxation I don't know
that's kind of on the I'm on the fence
on that one
um collective bargaining were later
accepted and institutionalized in ways
that insulated them from political
contention
and last each of these policy
achievements contributed to binding the
majority of African-American citizens to
the party and political Outlook most
responsible for them even though
African-American citizens were often
deliberately excluded from or last in
line for the benefits on offer
so exactly the period Jason discusses
1940 to 1970 is the period in which
progressive government emerges in the
United States and establishes itself
following the New Deal
so it's it's not like there wasn't a
framework for what happens there right
not just for the African-Americans he
describes but also the white white
workers he describes who experience
upward Mobility during this period so
why is the greatest period of upward
mobility in the United States under the
terms of progressive government
that's a question we should certainly
discuss
in the context of a growing economy in
the decades following World War II
Progressive policies helped to create
the largest middle class in the history
of Any Nation one built on Union
membership and relatively High wages for
people of modest skill and education
High marginal tax rates extremely high
marginal tax rates
and included access for the first time
to home ownership via inexpensive
government-backed long-term mortgages
one of the great financial Innovations
of the 20th century and also For the
First Time In This Very City access to
free public higher education
once again African-American citizens
were not the full beneficiaries of this
golden age of post-war growth liberalism
the National Labor Relations Act FHA
mortgage policies the GI Bill the
Federal Highway Act inaugurated nothing
short of a generational leap in upward
Mobility for the majority of white
workers
although these decades also saw the
first generation of African Americans to
obtain wide entry into industrial work
including into unionized industrial work
although Jason's right that there was
also a lot of exclusion in occupations
especially in the Building Trades
by and large African Americans remain
mostly locked out of access to Suburban
home ownership due to redlining and real
estate steering and of course they still
needed to fight for access to public
accommodations and educational access to
the professions
African-American citizens would
subsequently be disproportionately
represented among America's less
affluent less sheltered and less
well-educated citizenry despite the fact
that on Aggregate and here I agree with
Jason during these post-war decades
African Americans also experienced
upward Mobility along with the great
majority of U.S working-class citizens
in fact this contradiction is really at
the core of what the Civil Rights
Movement was about it was not merely a
question of ending racial discrimination
but fulfilling Rising expectations as
the 1964 March on Washington put it for
jobs and freedom leading to full
membership and participation in the
affluent society
and again here's where things get
contentious
the struggles of the 1960s decade
continue to cast a long Shadow not least
because they began to reshape what we
now mean by progressive government
this was the period in which
progressives envisioned extending the
benefits of the welfare state
to those who remained either excluded or
disadvantaged along lines of income and
race
its primary pillars were a series of
legislative and policy changes under the
Civil Rights Act the Voting Rights Act
and the Equal Opportunity Act
it also included a war on poverty that
extended welfare and health benefits to
the poor and elderly fair housing
legislation that sought to address a
long Legacy of substandard housing for
urban residents and substantive
exclusion from suburban homeownership
and last it involved the introduction of
new forms of what would be called
affirmative action in areas of
employment and education that had
previously been white preserves
but a more fundamental challenge was
also in the offing during this period
the effort to expand the U.S welfare
state was also beginning to confront the
contraction of if not substantive limits
to economic growth
a costly overseas war in Vietnam urban
riots and racial conflict a new age of
energy price shocks Automation and
overseas industrial competition set the
conditions for a structural change in
America's political economic order
as Paul volcker put it when taking the
Helm of the U.S federal reserve under
Jimmy Carter in 1979 with a mandate to
tame rampant inflation quote I see no
alternative the standard of living of
the American worker has to fall
rarely has an American policy maker been
more blunt or more truthful
the fact is that Progressive policy ran
aground on the stagflation of the 1970s
and the greatest casualties were once
again those who were least insulated
from economic shocks those who had been
the least able to benefit from the prior
Generations upward economic Mobility
including cross-generational transfers
of wealth through home ownership
though conservatives and many liberals
have chided the black poor and welfare
recipients for their thriflessness
and anti-social Behavior ever since
de-industrialization and the steady
Retreat from Progressive policy measures
supporting working class and poor
citizens was like gasoline poured on a
simmering fire
in turn the state's response was a
turned to Law and Order and a new
40-year experiment one that instead of
building the world's largest middle
class built the world's largest
experiment in incarcerating poverty
so maybe you think I just lost the
argument
let me explain what I mean
Jason might say it's all well and good
to point to the Past achievements of
progressive government although he
doesn't really highlight them in his own
comments of what's going on in the
period he discusses
maybe it even makes sense and helps to
explain why the majority of
African-American voters shifted so
decisively after the middle of the 20th
century toward the political party that
was Behind These achievements
the fact is that progressive government
ultimately failed it failed to sustain
the political economy of growth that
created one of the largest middle-class
populations in the history of Any Nation
and it failed to eliminate racial
discrimination and disparity
as Ronald Reagan famously put it rising
to the presidency in 1980 we fought a
war on poverty and poverty one
but the fact of the matter is both the
war on poverty and affirmative action
succeeded in ways we still fail to
appreciate
in 1959 the U.S poverty rate was an
estimated 22 percent this is across
racial lines
by 1975 it was closer to 12 percent
which is where it has remained
stubbornly up until this day
and that's something worth discussing
why did we move the needle on poverty
between 1965 and 1975 and then it came
to this solid place it has remained
despite changes in policy and
administrations for the last 40 years
there's a good book that just came out
by sociologist Matthew Desmond which
discusses this we can talk about that
perhaps
the Reagan Administration itself
commissioned a study that it later
shelved showing that between 1974 and
1980 the rate of minority and female
employment in businesses that contracted
with the federal government under
affirmative action mandates Rose between
15 and 20 percent while mostly
stagnating in Private Industry the
National Association of Manufacturers
surprisingly actually lobbied the Reagan
Administration
to not oppose affirmative action because
they actually wanted to be able to
diversify diversify their workforces and
of course looking ahead as late as 1976
83 percent of University students were
white
today it is closer to 50 percent
the reality is that the conservative
arguments against the progressive
history of civil rights legislation
involves a lot of free riding on
Progressive policy achievements and
often followed then by a bait and switch
the one thing conservatives have
generally been right at to foreground
and take seriously is that since the
1970s the U.S has faced unprecedented
challenges to economic growth
but the solutions they have proposed tax
cuts deregulation offshoring free trade
rarely got to the root of the problem
and in response to their own failures
conservatives have often leaned in to
racialized panics on the country's
poorest citizens I'm not saying that
this is what's Happening Here by the way
I'm not making that claim about what
Jason said or his arguments I'm making
that claim essentially about the Reagan
Administration
making the case that the black and brown
black black and brown Poor People's
cultural and moral deficiencies were
significantly if not entirely to blame
for poverty and its social ills for
example serve to justify the enactment
of draconian drug laws mass
incarceration cuts to social welfare and
public housing again like pouring
gasoline on a fire and far from being a
marginal argument this has been the
dominant conservative frame since the
1970s
since that time periods of conservative
control over the government in the
United States have sought with greater
and lesser success to reformer roll back
Progressive policy achievements
weakening trade unions reducing taxes on
corporations and Wealthy individuals
instituting work requirements for those
receiving welfare and Medicaid weakening
Financial occupational health safety and
environmental regulations on business
now of course there's more to say about
the conservative case against big
government and the administrative State
and conservatives have of course
Advanced reasonable arguments that
Progressive policy and especially the
focus on compensatory redistribution
through taxation runs the risk of
sapping innovation and Entrepreneurship
but it is no small irony that the
popularity of arguments for freeing the
market coincided with building the
world's largest carceral state
the biggest are the bigger irony of
course is that perhaps the greatest
achievement of the conservative policy
Vision was that it also changed the
character of progressive policy which
under the leadership of Bill Clinton and
later Barack Obama mostly shed its New
Deal Heritage in favor of supply side
free market-oriented policy including
free trade at the expense of labor
standards a timid regulatory agenda and
the institutionalization of
fundamentally scaled back commitments to
stabilize Labor's share of social wealth
and the substitution of punishment for
rehabilitation for those convicted of
crimes
so how is the broad Retreat from
Progressive policy worked out
did tax cuts and gender durable growth
did de-industrialization and free trade
create a high wage high employment
economy in the United States did
deregulation improve our water and
transportation infrastructures did the
conservative rollback of major civil
rights gains
produce more trust in our democracy or a
safer and Freer Public Square did a
technology and health Revolution stem
the fall of midlife mortality in the
United States well the answer to all
these questions of course is no
the crossroads where we stand today
indicates the need for not for less but
the need for more Progressive policy
this has even been glimpsed in certain
corners of the GOP today that has turned
against free trade overseas
interventionism and showed A Renewed
interest in U.S industrial policy and
Criminal Justice Reform
in short the real question is what
policy design best supports the public
welfare for the great majority what
policy design is best suited to
supporting an affording opportunity
sometimes government does need to get
out of the way for example to police and
incarcerate less or to defeat NIMBY
coalitions that restrict expansion of
low-income housing in wealthier
neighborhoods and sometimes government
needs to do more like sen like
incentivizing the transition to
renewable energy and creating
opportunities to develop new skills and
capacities through training and
education
all this too is the better part of the
legacy of progressive politics far from
being opposed to opportunity the
policies of progressive government have
in the past played a significant role in
creating the opportunities afforded by
American society and we need to see that
they do so again in the future thank you
[Applause]
model Jason seven minutes of rebuttal
the professor
referred on a number of occasions to
what has happened since 1965
or since 1970 is this on
okay the professor referred to uh on a
number of occasions which happened since
1965 or since 1970. I think he's
starting the story in the middle
which is why I wanted to start
in the 1940s
um a lot of the policies that he is
crediting
with outcomes today
predate
the existence of those policies at best
these policies like affirmative action
continued a pre-existing trend
and at a slower rate
than things were going prior to the
policy
I think there's also a little bit of
semantic game ship going on with the
definition of progressivism and the
period of progressivism which I think is
more commonly associated with the 1920s
than the 1940s
um Woodrow Wilson was the progressive
president who re-segregated the federal
government the Progressive Era of the
1920s brought us eugenics
um
that's not something I think we want to
return to I don't think it's anything
anybody here wants to return to
including the professor but that was the
Progressive Era
but the question at hand here is
how blacks fared
before these policies were put in place
and how they fared since in my opening
remarks I talked about
pre-1970 black advancement and now I
want to say a few words about the trends
since then
black underachievement today is almost
reflexively described
as a legacy of slavery or a legacy of
Jim Crow but I think it's better
understood as a legacy of
well-intentioned Great Society welfare
state expansions
mainly by subsidizing anti-social
Behavior
since the 1960s
black leaders have really prioritized
the integration of political
institutions with the goal of closing
racial and economic gaps
and at least in terms of electing more
blacks to office they've had a good deal
of success on this front by the early
1980s major U.S cities with large black
populations Cleveland to Detroit to
Chicago's Philadelphia's and so forth
had elected black Mayors almost all of
whom pushed for bigger government and
for special treatment for blacks
since 1970 the number of black elected
officials has grown from fewer than 1500
to more than ten thousand in this
country including of course a black
president
the problem is that all this political
clout
never really paid off economically for
the black poor
which is what we were told would happen
you look at how the black underclass
fared in these black run cities
Coleman Young's Detroit in the 1970s
Marion Barry's Washington D.C in the
1980s sharp James is Newark New Jersey
in the 1990s these black Mayors created
unbeatable political machines
in the name of helping the black poor
yet the poor became more impoverished on
their watch
in an era of increasing black political
clout and affirmative action
the black underclass lost ground
both in absolute terms and relative to
the white underclass in the 1970s and
80s and even into the 1990s the poorest
blacks in America saw their incomes
decline at more than double the rate of
the poorest whites in America
in the wake of the war on poverty black
labor force participation declined black
unemployment rates Rose and the black
nuclear family disintegrated
between the 1960s and the 1990s the
proportion of black children living with
both parents fell from two-thirds to
one-third
the pre-1970 era shows that what's
needed more than political saviors
racial preferences wealth redistribution
schemes is economic growth and
opportunity
tight labor markets are more beneficial
than affirmative action
having a black man in the home is more
important than having one in the White
House
a few years ago I wrote a column in the
Wall Street Journal on the prevalence of
violent crime in poor black
neighborhoods
and in the column I used a quote from
Martin Luther King
who once told a black congregation do
you know that Negroes are 10 of the
population in St Louis and responsible
for 58 of the crimes
King said we've got to face that
we've got to do something about our
moral standards
he said we know that there are many
things wrong in the white world
but there are many things wrong in the
black world too
we can't keep on blaming the white man
there are things we must do for
ourselves
after the column ran a number of readers
contacted the paper and accused me of
making up the quote
which comes from a 1961 Harper's
magazine profile of King by James
Baldwin of all people
some readers apparently just couldn't
believe that the nation's most prominent
civil rights leaders used to speak this
way about problems in the black
community and the role of personal
responsibility but such talk was typical
of that era
King and his generation of leaders
believed that whites obviously had a
role to play in changing a fundamentally
racist system
but they also understood that blacks had
a role to play
and they were willing to hold blacks
accountable
despite the legal and rampant racism
that existed at the time it was no
excuse
they asked something of black people
by contrast leaders today ask almost
nothing of blacks and spend much more
time making excuses for the kind of
anti-social behavior that prominent
black leaders of the king era would
regularly condemn and I think that has
to change
I'll stop there
seven minutes and we bottle nikel take
it away okay I'm free of my script now I
can just talk to you
um
so I think there's like you know I don't
think I was accused of of semantics
around progressivism so so let me just
put the cards on the table you know
progressivism is a is a loose term right
what I really mean is a public good
orientation towards government I'm in
the idea that government actually has a
role in Social protection in redressing
and uh in some ways ameliorating
contradictions that emerge from an
economy that produces inequality from a
set of social relationships that
generates inequality that's what
progressives essentially believe in we
believe in more equality and we believe
in policies that Foster that now I
couldn't agree with Jason Moore that the
political economic design of our society
is the route to to this this question
but he does this this maneuver in his in
his presentation where the political
economic design that emerged in the
period from the 1940s to the 1970s
somehow has nothing to do with
governmental policy but it has
everything to do with governmental
policy governmental policies that
involved interventions and markets in in
mortgage markets in labor markets
um and and in and in the organization of
of race relations it's as well because
the first statutes that mandate
non-discrimination get put on the books
by the Roosevelt administration in the
1940s that's really the beginning of
anti-discrimination law in the modern
period so there's a continuity between
what happens in the 1940s and the 1960s
the reason there's an effort to extend
the welfare state in the 1960s is
because African Americans in many ways
are locked out of some of these benefits
unions are still discriminatory housing
markets are still discriminatory the
there are there are problems related to
the existence of Jim Crow in the South
that are very specific and that have to
be undone and fought against and if we
want to bring out Martin Luther King
into this conversation absolutely a true
quote from King and I've studied King
pretty extensively and is he's obviously
one of the great thinkers that we should
all examine and King has a pretty
complicated view of the world but what
he says in 1965 is is that we've
achieved we've achieved racial Justice
at bargain rates
and what he means by that is is that
civil rights legislation is not going to
be enough
to actually change the political
economic structure of American society
that has engendered disproportionate
rates of black poverty and unemployment
which have always been the case which
were the case in the 1940s and 1950s as
well
but what happens after the 1960s is is
that that does not come to pass
those kinds of changes the political
economic redesign of the American uh
standard of living actually goes in a
very very different direction
and we are actually now at the end of
another Arc of History where we're
looking out and seeing the results of
that we're seeing the results of
de-industrialization we're seeing the
results of globalization and free trade
we're seeing the results of the
financialization of the economy and
though that those political economic
questions or questions for policy makers
and I agree that policy makers who've
described themselves as Progressive have
in many ways failed in the face of
answering these questions as well so I'm
not here to shill for the Democratic
Party
right but I don't think that you can say
that the kind of approach that our
conservative governments have taken
whether under uh Ronald Reagan or George
W bush have done much to advance the
case of producing a fair more equal
economy 23 of American jobs right now
are considered low way low-wage jobs an
American low-wage workers make about
two-thirds of what low-wage workers make
in the rest of the oecd
the advanced economies of the world
so how do you think that affects the
majority of African Americans who occupy
the lower rungs of the economy
African Americans had been stably poor
and overrepresented in the poor and
stably over-represented in prisons since
this new kind of economy emerged in the
1980s and 1990s
that is something that actually needs to
be addressed with policy
and I agree that progressives should
lean less into racially targeted
policy proposals aimed at increasing
representation in the professional
managerial class
and more into policies like a living
wage
like Universal Health Care
like
access to housing
public housing and other kinds of
housing
increasing opportunities for home
ownership increasing Financial
innovations that serve the unbanked
rather than allowing the poor to
continually be overcharged
and underpaid for the work they do
because they don't have advantages in
the market economy and I work a lot with
people in prison so I know a lot about
the overweening aspects
of the administrative State and how
inefficient and unresponsive it is to
human needs but we actually need more
Criminal Justice Reform not less in some
ways I think to be honest our political
landscape is being scrambled now and
maybe these labels Progressive and
conservative don't actually serve us
that well
but I would say that in general I find
progressives to be more on my side of
these questions than most conservatives
and I'm not even saying Jason is a
conservative but the fact is and this
goes to something Nick Gillespie said
the other day Libertarians and
socialists and I consider myself more of
a socialist than a progressive
have a lot in common when it comes to
thinking about what it means to
actualize human Freedom this is
paraphrasing Nick and what are the root
systems that prevent that actualization
from occurring
and I think if we're going to look at
root systems right now we have to look
at the way that we're policed and
punished and we have to look at the way
in which low-wage workers
and low wage and poor members of our
society are underpaid and overcharged so
underpaid as workers and overcharged
disc consumers and end the processes
that prey on them to make a fairer
economy that will come through
Progressive policy that will create more
opportunity in American society
for African Americans and for everyone
else
[Applause]
okay
uh thanks to you both we now start the
the Q a portion of the evening you can
line up and ask questions over there uh
let me start by taking moderators
prerogative to ask a couple of questions
of our Debaters uh a question addressed
to you Jason uh your narrative is that
uh that blacks did better uh from uh
1940 to the progress and especially the
black white cap closed uh from 1940 to
1970 and then reversed the blacklight
got reversed and progressed into well
narrowing they didn't close I'm sorry
they were narrowing and narrowing at a
faster rate than the post 1970. sorry
yes indeed I should have said narrowing
not closed of course uh they but but
you're saying despite that uh that this
happened uh despite I mean not could not
have happened because of of the policies
like affirmative action more welfare and
and more more blacks in politics than
ever before this is the progress was
happening prior to that but but uh why
but why reject the policy since 1970
anyway uh just because uh the progress
was happening before these things
happened why can't why isn't it good to
have more more blacks in politics more
affirmative action and more welfare why
are they bad things in what why can't
they be helpful things in any case why
aren't they helpful
well I would not and was not arguing
against having more blacks in politics I
think that that's uh uh a good thing I'm
not arguing that um blacks should
disengage
politically my point is that political
power and political clout does not
automatically lead to Upward Mobility
for a group and that's a a a case that's
been proven not just with black history
but with the history of many other
groups
who Who Rose economically first and
engaged in politics later and that has
been the more typical pattern for a
group Rising a minority group rising
from from poverty to Prosperity so so
blacks political success is not
something that
um
Uh I that has automatically translated
into economic success and and and yet
that is what the Civil Rights leadership
has been focused on uh primarily since
1965. the thinking was that
um we got the Voting Rights pass act uh
the Voting Rights Act passed and if we
can just get more of Our Own in office
the rest will take care of itself and I
went through that history of black
Mayors and poverty rates to show that
the rest has not taken care of itself
well well put a fine point on the other
aspects of it affirmative action welfare
why can't those things help affirmative
action black lives matter I I think the
in terms of affirmative action
um I think the progress has slowed
in the wake of affirmative action
policies there was faster progress I I
think policies like affirmative action
have hampered black upward Mobility
uh and we you know we've had affirmative
action policies in place for a half
century now so we don't have to
speculate about uh what will happen
there's some natural experiments out
there that have already occurred the
University of California system back in
the mid-1990s ended race-based
admissions throughout the entire
University of California system
after it did that black graduation rates
went up
and not by a little bit by more than 50
percent including in the harder
disciplines the more challenging
disciplines of math and science and
engineering grade point averages of of
3.5 or higher among blacks increased by
more than 50 percent after the
University of California system ended
racial preferences in college admissions
so a policy that had been put in place
to increase the ranks of the black
middle class to increase the number of
black doctors and lawyers and Engineers
had in practice
led to fewer
of these individuals than we would have
had in the absence of the policy so
aside from whether you think affirmative
action is constitutional
or make sense in an increasingly
pluralistic society to have a racial
spoil system like that in place uh the
other question is whether it actually
works
and I would argue that 50 years of it
shows that it is not working as intended
uh comment from you uh Nick Hill on
anything that Jason has said you know
the question oh well there's no question
that affirmative action has worked to
expand the ranks of the black
professional managerial class over the
last like 40 50 years there's no
question
um and and that's been shown by
countless studies
um the University of California example
I don't know for sure that what was just
said is exactly right one thing that
definitely happened after affirmative
action was outlawed in the University of
California system was that the flagship
campuses saw a tremendous drop in
African-American Latino uh enrollments
and
black and Latino enrollments went up at
the at the satellite campuses so there
was less access to some of the Premier
parts of the University California
system when affirmative action went out
but
the the the real issue for me and I
think the really important issue is is
that we spend an inordinate amount of
time thinking about the number of like
black students to get into Harvard or
whatever and we actually don't think
about the whole educational landscape
and how it was transformed since the
1970s public higher education was free
in the University California system
until the 1970s it was free in the city
of New York until the 1970s so now we
know what what's happened since that
time is is that public higher education
has become extremely expensive
the greatest barriers to going to school
for people or the cost that's the
greatest barrier and that's the one
thing that can't seem that we can't seem
to reduce
right what do we get since the 1970s we
got cheap electronics
and we got
costly education
we got cheap consumer goods
and we got
really expensive Health Care
we got a lot of cheap things that kind
of made us have a feeling that we have a
decent standard of living but the cost
of housing skyrocketed
so this is about political economy right
and I really think that these are the
things that we should be talking about
because when we're talking about people
of modest means people who are who have
to work for a wage people that don't
have inherited wealth
people that come into the world with
disadvantages based upon past
discrimination
then these are the things that really
matter
and affirmative action has helped in
some Realms where it was designed to do
so it has helped to diversify the
professions
it is especially helped white women
Yale's faculty in 1976 was 1.6 percent
women it's faculty of Arts and Sciences
can you believe that 1.6 women
and now it's closer to 50 percent that's
a good thing
that was part of what affirmative action
did it didn't just do stuff for African
Americans it's not just a policy that
was even just about African-Americans it
was about the gendered and racial
segmentation of the professions and that
changed since the 1970s in a way that's
a really really good thing for our
society whether it should continue now
and what should be the policy now is an
open question and I'm certainly willing
to have that conversation
um I guess Jason what perhaps you can
have an exchange of Jason says make a
comment yeah the professor says as if
it's just uh as true as the fact that
the sky is blue or water is wet that
affirmative action
um
is is working
and and that it is increasing the ranks
of the black middle class
um again there was a black middle class
before affirmative action it has
continued to grow but at a much lower
rate I quoted Robert Putnam directly who
looked at this data and said despite the
fact that white educational gain
attainment was also Rising between 1940
and 1970 black educational attainment
was Rising even faster before 19 between
1940 and 1970 but after 1970 that
catch-up progress drastically slowed in
the case of high school and actually
ended in the case of college this is a
math problem when you're talking about
growing from a really tiny base of
course the rate
we're not talking about simply absolute
gains we're talking about gains Relic
black gains relative to White gains
whites weren't standing still they were
advancing as well and blacks were
catching up at a much much faster rate
prior to affirmative action higher
education than they were in the in the
during the affirmative action era that
is the point the issue is to judge the
value of these policies and I think you
can compare them using empirical data
what was going on pre-1970 what's been
going on since and the data shows that
faster progress was taking place in the
pre-affirmative action era I don't I
don't think the data actually shows that
yeah I could also quote Richard Vetter
and they're quoting census data and I've
also just quoted quoted statistics
Harvard's faculty in the 1970s had zero
black faculty among the tenure flat
faculty in the early 1970s it's about
eight percent now so you can look across
the universities in terms of the
diversification of faculties and student
bodies since the 1970s and there were
black people who taught at Ivy League
institutions I'm saying prior to I'm
saying 70. I'm saying among the tenured
faculty in the in arts and science Tom
Seoul taught a Cornell yeah no I'm
talking about I was I mentioned Harvard
just then but I'm not saying that there
was no there were no black faculty at
any uh and any institutions of higher
education of course I'm not saying that
but I'm saying that those numbers have
absolutely increased and only because of
affirmative action not only because of
affirmative without affirmative action
blacks can't teach in the eye no no no
that's not all what I'm saying that is
not what that is not what I'm saying I'm
saying affirmative action policies have
been part of the diversification of
higher education in a way that has been
helpful and in a way that has actually
worked that's what I'm saying
that's all I'm saying it's really simple
Derek Bach who is president of Harvard
wrote the shape of the river in 1976
they studied
several hundred no no no I mean it came
out it came in the 1980s but nice study
is based upon a group a cohort that went
in under affirmative action 1976
and it should what what they found there
in that in that book was out of the 700
people that they studied
that at the end of that college cohorts
experience over 30 percent had ended up
with Advanced or professional degrees
over 300 of them had become Civic
leaders
and I think around 120 had become
Business Leaders I have it someone in my
notes in any way the point what they
found no that is what they think that is
not what they found I can tell you what
they found now that's that is not and
and what they and what they showed in
that study was that those rates were
remarkably similar to and very close to
uh the white cohort that they compared
it to no yeah that book attempted or or
suggested that it was measuring uh
racial preferences in higher education
what Bach and Bowen did not do however
is to disaggregate the blacks who had
been admitted under racial preferences
from the blacks who had not been
admitted under racial preferences but
got into the school Under the same
credentials as everyone else they never
disaggregated that data
they just looped it all together and
reported averages the entire argument
over affirmative action
is not whether
blacks can can do well at these schools
it's whether the blacks who are let in
with lower credentials can do better at
these schools Bowen and Bach did not
disaggregate that data not only did they
not disaggregate it they wouldn't
release
their findings so that other social
scientists could check their findings
and see if they could come up with the
same results that book did not do what
you were suggesting it did well that was
the finding of the book I mean you
you've offered a discrediting of their
finding and that's what social
scientists do they discredit each
other's findings I mean I I didn't come
I didn't come here I didn't come here to
really debate like the merits of
affirmative action I think that we can
we can find like we can find examples of
where affirmative action has succeeded
absolutely and where it has has had
benefits that's really it's really a
minimal claim may I just make just put a
finer Point since we've been discussing
put a final point on the question which
gets back to the question I put to you
Jason are you saying that affirmative
action didn't help or are you saying
that affirmative action hurt and if so
how
it's it's it's done more harm than good
and in a number of ways
um hey I I've just believe it's
unconstitutional well we're talking
about the harm or the good yeah Supreme
consequential inside that um but but
regardless of whether it's it's it's
constitutional I think the data show
that it's done more harm than good and
it's done more harm than good primarily
by setting up smart kids to fail
um I'll give you an example uh
there's a study done of MIT students
black students at MIT some years ago
black students at MIT had scored the
90th percentile on the math portion of
the SAT of all kids in the country
90th percentile
but among their peers at MIT they were
in the 10th percentile
so black students who would be hitting
it out of the park
at a less selective Institution
was struggling at MIT
you mentioned how after California ended
its racial preference policies and
college admissions black enrollment
initially fell at the flagship schools
of UC Berkeley and UCLA
you're right it did those students
however went on
to enroll at UC Santa Cruz
and UC Santa Barbara where they could
handle the work and they graduated
what is the point of flunking out of
Berkeley instead of graduating from UC
Santa Barbara what is the point of
flunking out of MIT or struggling having
to switch to an easier major
rather than graduating in the major you
want to study in from the institution
and that's what I mean when I say that
it is set up smart kids to fail it is
not about these kids not being smart not
being able to handle the work anywhere
not belonging in college it's about
whether they can handle the pace and
it's it has to do and it doesn't it's
not limited to race
um
who are let in because their parents
went to the school legacies students who
were LED in because of athletic ability
with with lower credentials than the
average student also struggle at these
schools if if you decided to let in
left-handed blondes with lower
credentials than the average student at
Harvard you would see left-handed
blondes concentrating in the bottom of
their class you would see them
struggling with the work you would see
them dropping out at higher rates that
is what is being done to black people in
the name of helping them no restriction
on the like well okay we at least we
have the the difference is clear and you
may be able to speak do you want to make
a comment or can we go to a question to
kill yeah I mean I I don't have that
much more to say about it okay I think
we put like way too much emphasis on
affirmative okay all right and that
hasn't really been the the sort of
weight of of the arguments that I've
been making tonight at all about
progressives
because it's a progressive policy it is
one Progressive policy and it's one
Progressive policy that has had some
benefits and it's certainly one perfect
aggressive policy that has engendered a
very large amount of contention and it's
probably about to be ruled
unconstitutional um yeah well okay
fairness but there's also a way I mean I
mean the military has been one of the
biggest institutions that's been in
support of affirmative action
affirmative action has really been about
diversifying Pathways to leadership
that's why people end up focusing on
these these very elite institutions now
has that has that occurred in in some
institutions is is the military a good
example of having successfully
established Pathways to leadership by
using what they would admit is
affirmative action absolutely so I don't
know if you want to contradict the whole
idea of the what the U.S military has
done as an institution one of the most
respected institutions in American
society I mean go ahead but I would say
that there are probably examples of
success so so I'm not saying that it's
the only I'm not saying it's the only
thing that we should be hinging this
argument on you know I think they're
actually really legitimate agreements I
mean legitimate disagreements to have
about affirmative action and I know why
people get so upset about it seems it it
really is a contradictory policy we
should be a race-blind society and then
we find that we have to take race into
account to deal with something like this
but you know it's it's it's a very I
mean we should have a separate debate on
this topic because it could go on and on
okay yes question for the audience yes
thank you a question please ask a
question
I want to focus on some different uh
Progressive policies like uh
welfare and various handouts of
government policies of various sorts I
do write quite a bit about this subject
myself so I follow a lot of the
statistics and I'm going to ask about
some specific statistics relating to
Manhattan because and this question is
mainly for the negative although you've
cited National statistics there are more
granular statistics and there are
particular ones relating to our little
home county here which is the wealthiest
large County in the country when they
first started collecting poverty
statistics as you mentioned the poverty
rate for the country in the 60s was
about 16 percent Manhattan was 10
percent
today as you mentioned the poverty rate
for the country has come down to about
13 percent the poverty rate for
Manhattan is 20 percent Manhattan has
the most generous government handout
programs for the poor of any place in
the country the most generous public
housing the highest percentage per
capita public housing the most generous
Medicaid Program the most generous
welfare program special additional
welfare programs for people who've run
out of the federal benefits the most
generous in every respect and yet
and the wealthiest large County in the
country our poverty rate has gone from
well below the national average to well
above completely inexcusable number my
interpretation of this is that large
numbers of the poor have been bought
into dependency by government handouts
and that this has disproportionately
affected blacks to their tremendous
detriment what's your interpretation uh
it's a question for doing a kill clearly
yes yeah I mean that's that's the common
argument I mean I I don't know I look at
it Manhattan and I see the most
expensive country the most expensive one
of the most expensive cities in the
world to live in so it doesn't surprise
me that the people who are struggling to
live here in different pockets of the
city who don't have uh a lot of wealth
are struggling I mean I mean I look out
at the whole society right now and I
think this question of opportunity like
we're supposed to just have opportunity
who feels like they have like a lot of
opportunity when they like look out at
the world right now especially like the
students and young people in this room
unless you're going to like inherit some
wealth from your parents you know what
kind of what kind of uh wage do you
imagine earning that's going to actually
allow you to rent an apartment in
Manhattan and then and then pay the cost
of food that has like gone up by like 12
or 15 percent in the last couple of
years and then if you have dependents
take care of them you know yeah it is
absolutely true that like the habits of
poor people might not be the best habits
uh and I as I said I work with a lot of
people who come from Brownsville the
poorest the poorest county in New York
City in Brooklyn and in other parts of
the Bronx is the poorest well no brat
well Brownsville Brownsville and Bronx
are very very close in any case you said
County uh I'm okay uh ZIP code ZIP code
I meant to say I know I'm talking to a
status station so so I defer to you
um
and my my experience of of those places
are they are places where there is hyper
concentrated poverty there's very very
high unemployment there's very very
little they're very poor public schools
and public services there's very poor
housing options and people are really
locked in and those are the those are
the zip codes that send the most people
into the prison system
and when I've met those mostly men in
the prison system most of whom ended up
dropping out of high school and getting
involved in the informal or underground
economy because that's the way they made
a living mostly the drug trade
I find people who have a lot of
initiative who have a lot of desire to
learn who have a lot of desire to work
and who actually are able to seize and
embrace opportunity when that
opportunity is given to them I don't see
people who are thriftless and like bred
into dependency I think the problem
really is a lack and a dearth of
opportunity for poor people in certain
parts of our city
a question uh was put to nikhil can do
you want to comment on the kill's answer
and on the question Jason
um well I thought the question related
out very well I mean I I saw statistics
somewhere that said the median amount of
time that a family in New York City has
spent in public housing
is 20 years
20 years housing
meant to be
temporary
for people who have hit a rough patch
has become a multi-generational trap
why should public housing be temporary
coming in a moment please well that's
okay that was its original intent
that you would move in
uh until you got back on your feet and
move out and I am in favor
of a safety net being in place for
people I I am not someone who believes
well you know we need to get rid of of
of the safety net but there is the risk
if you make benefits too generous of
them becoming a Lorna trap my larger
observation would just be
uh
progressivism has created a lot of these
problems what has made
New York unaffordable if not Progressive
policies that you know prevent the
building of affordable housing rent
control policies uh the same can be said
of San Francisco another place that
progressives have long run and and and
you see minorities and low-income people
fleeing because they can't afford to
live there anymore I mean San
Francisco's black population is
something like half of what it was 40
years ago and it's not because
conservative Republicans Run San
Francisco
I I
I absolutely concede that progressives
so-called
running cities have not
done well by their poorer residents
absolutely but that's not because they
enforce Progressive policies is because
they can cater to financial and real
estate interests primarily that's that's
the reason why do why do we have it why
do we have the kind of city that we have
because we actually don't have a city
that creates the possibility of like
good paying jobs and affordable housing
for the majority of its residents
we need policies like that
next question this question first it's
for nikhil I think you said that uh
blacks in this country have been stably
over-represented among the poor and
stably
over-represented among prisons in terms
of incarceration and you seem to blame
this at least in part on the
deregulatory free market-oriented
policies starting in the 80s and then
onward
but my understanding from Reading Thomas
soul and other economists is that if we
look at certain black African immigrant
groups in the United States such as
Nigerian Americans even when they've
stayed in this country been in this
country for multiple Generations there's
no educational attainment Gap with white
Americans there's no over-representation
you know in poverty or in incarceration
and that seems to undercut what you said
so how would you respond to that
ah Jason is the expert on Thomas Soul so
I don't know I don't I don't know I
don't know Thomas sewell's work um
uh
African-American
populations migrant populations coming
from the south became concentrated in in
urban areas
in the period following the the two
great migrations in the middle of the
20th century
that that is the the real that that's
the real source of kind of concentrated
poverty in in in urban places and that
concentrated poverty
uh is intensified by housing policy and
by the lack of access to the places the
economy is growing right where wealth is
growing
industry is moving out of the Cities
housing wealth is being concentrated in
Suburban areas and urban populations are
essentially being abandoned one of the
things that Mike Davis talks about in
his book city of quartz about Los
Angeles is that there's a jobs fair in
South Central Los Angeles where a
corporation is hiring I I don't remember
which business it was is is is
advertised that it's hiring 50 jobs and
about 2 000 people show up with a line
around the block for those jobs so there
is absolutely a crisis a massive crisis
of employment where people live
that begins to happen in the period that
we understand to be the period of
de-industrialization and that is the
beginning of the the urban crisis of the
1970s that leads to not a new industrial
policy
a new approach to jobs and training but
to a law and order approach
that essentially tries to incarcerate
poverty
that's my understanding of what happens
I don't know specifically the story
about what Nigerian immigrants are able
to accomplish or why they're able to
accomplish what they're able to
accomplish
or or any other number of groups right
but I do know that this is what happens
to African Americans
come into mutation
the the
um
the chance of the first party your
question I think it's it's you have to
be careful about comparing immigrants
and natives immigrants are
self-selecting
um they tend to be more motivated most
of us are going to are going to die
where we were born at least in the same
country
um uh immigrants are people who are who
are self-motivated more motivated than
the average person to pick up and start
over in a new country
um and and it's it's difficult to
compare that with with uh people already
in the country so you have to be careful
about that
um
but what you do say about second and
third generation uh immigrants having
better outcomes than native blacks I
think uh that's an argument that culture
is has a lot more to do to it uh than
anything else than race I would say or
racism
um but the professor said or seem to
suggests that blacks moving into
Northern cities
built concentrations of poverty and made
them worse off I could not disagree more
the black migration out of the South is
one of the reasons I could cite those
figures of what was happening between
1940 and 1970. it wasn't just the
wartime economy
blacks and it's not just that blacks
were leaving the South per se
they were leaving rural areas which tend
to be poorer in moving to cities which
tend to be richer they were doing so in
both the South and also moving North
into Northern cities this was a huge net
benefit
for the black population in America
during that period I mean just for
starters doing
the same job in Detroit that you were
doing in Mobile Alabama probably paid
three or four times
would it paid in Mobile Alabama
so blacks were increasing their years of
education they were moving North into
cities where they there qualified for
higher paying jobs and again you you
you've mentioned the D industrialization
thesis a number of times and I just want
to push back a little bit on that
um
the the industries left the cities in
the 70s
the riots happened in the 60s you're
getting the order wrong
the the companies didn't leave the
cities
the riots happened first is my point the
blacks weren't rioting because industry
had left
that's not what I said no but but what
you're saying you're you're suggesting
that industry abandoned the inner city
which led to the social disintegration
of these of these environments what I'm
saying is the social disintegration
predates the industries leaving the city
well the I mean de-industrialization
actually begins in the early 1960s it
doesn't it starts in the early 1960s
it's a lot it's a much longer process
that unfolds over that period
there's a there's a movement out of of
the urban industrial North that's really
beginning around like 1963 1964. it's
it's a lot it's a much it's a much
longer process over the period from the
1960s to the 1980s it doesn't happen in
like one Fell Swoop and the reason the
thing the the problems of concentrated
poverty in urban areas that emerge out
of the migration are actually much more
related to housing segregation which is
a factor in shaping black life in the
urban north and is a part of what builds
up the kind of conflicts and tensions
that erupt in the 1960s so I I mean
there there is a there is a complicated
story with a lot of different moving
pieces but but I'm not saying that
de-industrialization was some kind of
like like like like single cause what I
am saying is is that when we when we
want to understand the declining
fortunes of African-American Urban
residents beginning in the 1970s that
begin to lead to a different kind of
policy approach of incar what I'm
calling incarcerating poverty but we
really have to trace it back to the the
long Arc of de-industrialization and
where black populations that are trapped
in urban areas end up at that point
because those are the those are the
those are really the people who are
being sent most in greatest numbers into
the prisons I mean the American prison
population in early 19th in the early
1970s is only about 300 000 people it's
very small
and it's by the 1990s it's over 2
million so it's really the period from
the 70s 70s to the 90s that you you see
mass incarceration take off I mean talk
about exponential that's when you saw
crime rates take off well I mean that's
that's again another another
conversation but the the reality is is
that primary separate conversation
because crime rates are actually
dropping in the in the period in which
mass incarceration is rising not in the
1960s and 70s and 80s cry I mean this is
where you have the order wrong crime
rates are rising in the late 1960s but
when mass incarceration actually takes
off crime rates are dropping in the
1970s and 1980s primates were not
dropping in the 1970s and 80s they are
that they continued right relative to
the early 90s relative to where they
were in the 1960s they are going down in
the 1970s crime rates kind of go like
this in that period Then mass
incarceration just goes like this it
just goes straight up you can't make the
argument that Massacre incarceration is
simply a response to rise in crime rates
I mean maybe you can but that again
would be an entire debate that we would
have to prepare for but I don't think
that that's accurate at all and I think
you can actually go and look at a book
like golden gulad you can look at the
work of Bruce Western you can look at
any number of people who have Elizabeth
Hinton who've laid out the history of
mass incarceration in the United States
it does not correlate to Rising crime
Rising crime goes up it does go up in
the 1960s and there is a police response
but crime also goes down and when crime
goes down incarceration rates are still
going up okay uh
I'm sorry to say that I thought maybe we
had time for one more question I would I
would just quickly say that some people
think
crime goes down when incarceration rates
go up
that's that's certainly Fair they think
that's a logical outcome yeah that's a
that's it okay okay
um I have to say first of all that both
Debaters have consented to come to the
Lively after party and have some of the
apple cider and and they're both
obviously eminently approachable guys
and uh and so you can chat with them
later especially you people have been
lined up to ask questions I'm sorry to
frustrate you but we do have to go to
the summary portion of the evening five
minutes for you uh Jason to summarize
your argument do you want to take the
podium
no
one of the problems
with using racism as a sort of blanket
explanation
for racial disparities
and bias
is that racism and discrimination and
bias have been the constants
I think a lot of progressive policies
ignore that fact
but anyone who's looked
societies down through history
you find racism and discrimination and
bias everywhere
what you don't find
is that the group being targeted
always winds up at the bottom
economically
that's not what you find
in fact it's not unusual to find a hated
racial or ethnic minority group
outperforming
the majority group that does the
discriminating
you can look at the performance of the
ethnic Chinese in Southeast Asia the
Lebanese and West Africa Jews in Europe
Indians in East Africa and on and on
obviously these aren't perfect apples
apples comparisons and the experience of
blacks in the U.S is unique in many ways
but you can also compare blacks that
were previous era to blacks today
and when you do you find yet another
example by racism in and of itself is an
inadequate explanation for black
outcomes today
let me close by noting that this concept
of self-help and self-development
that I think characterized that earlier
black era and that I think is essential
to Black advancement today
is something that black leaders once
understood All Too Well in this country
and at a time when blacks faced
infinitely more obstacles
than they face in the third decade of
the 21st Century
Frederick Douglass a former slave said
in 1865 that everybody had asked him and
other abolitionists what to do with the
Negro
he said I've had but one answer from the
beginning do nothing with us
the apples will not remain on the tree
of Their Own Strength Let Them Fall
and if the Negro cannot stand on his own
legs let him fall also
all I ask is
give him a chance to stand on his own
legs
Douglas was essentially saying give
blacks
equal opportunity and then leave us
alone
Booker T Washington another former slave
echoed that sentiment
he said it is important and right that
all privileges of the law be ours
but it is vastly more important
that we be prepared for the exercise of
these privileges
the Douglas in Washington didn't play
down the need for the government to
secure equal rights for blacks
and I'm not playing that down either
and both were optimistic that they would
get equal rights eventually
though neither man lived to see that day
but both men also understood the limits
of government benevolence
blacks would have to ready themselves
to meet the far bigger challenge of
being in a position to take advantage of
opportunities
once equal rights had been secured
the history of progressive social
policies is largely a history of
ignoring this wisdom
and I think the better path forward for
blacks lies in rejecting these policies
and instead looking to and learning from
what blacks were doing successfully
in a previous era to get ahead thank you
[Applause]
so I've tried to make an argument
tonight here that doesn't actually lean
too heavily into the exceptionalism of
African Americans in American Life
African-Americans exist among the
working class and
over-represented among the poor in this
country and there are reasons for that
that that comes from the legacies of not
having wealth
um slavery Jim Crow
residential segregation redlining
exclusion from unions exclusion from the
professions
it was actually Nixon's labor secretary
George Schultz who made the first
comment about affirmative action he said
we've had we've had a affirmative action
policy for the greater part of our
history the target was Zero zero African
Americans in these areas
and yes absolutely African-Americans
struggled persevered created communities
created livelihoods uplifted themselves
through their own agency in all kinds of
ways that are part of the truly
inspiring story of black history in this
country
and that happened through the aid of
allies abolitionists
people who struggled alongside them
people who helped them escape slavery
people who supported communities that
were under attack in places like St
Louis and Detroit and Harlem where race
riots in Chicago where race riots
occurred with great frequency wherever
you had black populations
gathered
but it was really only after the 1930s
and 1940s that you get the beginning of
a transformation in American society
that creates a trajectory towards a more
racially inclusive one
and we do have a more racially inclusive
society today and that is in fact
progress
progress a word that is included in the
word Progressive
and that progress came about not simply
through the actions of people
in the marketplace although that was
part of the story
it came about through
the development of Institutions and
policies that created greater terrains
of opportunity
the biggest Progressive piece of
legislation really of the mid-century
was the one that gave workers the right
to organize into trade unions
and although trade unions did exclude
African Americans in some trades
African-American entry into trade unions
is actually a huge part of the story of
black progress after World War II that
is not being told here
we spend a lot of time
arguing about affirmative action which
is a controversial policy and
constitutional terms I agree we spend a
lot of time arguing about transfer
payments to the poorest citizens and
their supposedly pathological Behavior
the great majority of African Americans
are just working people like everyone
else
and they look out on this society as I
think most of us do today and they do
not see a society with great opportunity
just waiting for us if we just apply
ourselves
we came from an era in which there were
better paying jobs there was more
affordable education
and we should be looking forward to an
Era where that's true again
including access to the kind of health
care we need because the real
convergence that's happening right now
between black and life white chances is
downward
the convergence is towards the bottom
downward Mobility
and not just for poor people who are
people of color but for poor white
people as well
the future will come about by Reviving
and renewing a progressive social policy
not by abandoning it and that's the
purchase of the argument I've tried to
make tonight that involves black people
and African Americans and it involves
the rest of us as well thank you
[Applause]
thank you
please keep your seats and Jane please
open the voting again yes no or
undecided on the resolution a uh upper
mobility of uh for black Americans lives
in rejecting the policies of progressive
government while making the most of the
opportunities offered by American
society I have in my hand the soul form
Tootsie Roll To whom this thing will be
thrown
based upon who wins the voting and uh
it's just a Tootsie Roll throwing it is
not dangerous uh Jason uh and uh but
while we're doing the voting uh I want
to announce that on Saturday there will
be an event that I am touting if you put
into your website into your search
engine the take take Human Action tour
take Human Action tour then there will
be an event on 84th Street and Broadway
in a big Hall it's uh it will be an all
day event of Libertarians including Dave
Smith Tom woods majoure and there will
be a rousing luncheon speaker who will
be me at this event that take Human
Action tour this coming Saturday put
that into your website and maybe I can
see some of you there well three weeks
from today we're going to have another
debate that touches on Race Thursday
April 20th University of South Carolina
professor of History Woody Holton will
defend the resolution the New York Times
book The 1619 project and the Hulu video
series based on it are important
contributions to our understanding of
slavery and the role of African
Americans in American history against
aier senior fellow Phil Magnus uny Sue
students of course invited to come you
two Debaters free tickets for you both
if you want to come to that debate on
April 20th about the 1619 project on May
22nd uh Monday May 22nd Northwestern
University professor of Law and
philosophy professor and and of Law and
philosophy Andrew comb Andrew koppelman
will defend the resolution
libertarianism has been thoroughly
corrupted by delusion greed and disdain
for the week
and
taking the negative will be me
um
and uh uh June in June we are taking a
show in the road as usual as we did uh
the past two Junes we're going up to
pork fest called pork fest because its
full name is porcupine Fest it's not Pig
Fest it's porcupine fast and it's a huge
event going over the space of of several
days on many acres of land with
Pavilions uh I'm going to be staying at
a hotel others camp out and stay in
other places yeah hundreds and hundreds
of people come to this event there will
be two debates that the soul form will
hold up at pork fest one of them will
involve David Friedman he is in fact the
illustrious son of Milton Friedman he
will defend the resolution the right way
to persuade people of libertarianism is
by showing them that its outcomes are
superior by their standards without any
resort to the a flawed non-aggression
principle that's the the resolution
David Friedman will defend and once
again taking the negative will be me but
pork fest uh if you go I'll just put
pork fest into your website and you'll
find that tickets are on sale I hope to
see you up there it is a six hour drive
up to New Hampshire but it's not such a
bad drive it's not far from Boston I'm
thinking uh Jane that you have the
results of the debate uh so I'm going to
pause and have them read right now
okay uh the resolution uh was uh that
again uh that blacks should progress
should reject the policy of progressive
government while making the most of the
opportunities offered by American
society the yes vote went from 48.6
percent to uh to to
66.97 so it picked up
18.35 percentage points uh the no vote
uh that's the number to beat the no vote
went from 15.6 to 18.35 it picked up 2.8
percentage points so by a reasonable
margin the yes vote had it Jason
sorry
thank you to you both please come to the
party
uh no